what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is a channel
where we talk about all things
data data science statistics and
programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so this is going to be the third video
in my julia tutorial series
now in the first video we covered how to
download and install
julia and get set up in an environment
that's going to work for you
and then in the second tutorial we
covered how to use the data frames
package
just to manipulate and transform your
data just to get it into a nice
clean and usable format so you can take
that data set and do something more
exciting with
well now in this tutorial we're going to
do something more exciting with that
data
specifically visualizations now
there's a lot of different packages in
julia for visualization
there's plots that's the most popular
one there's gadfly which is a
slightly more mature one than that but
then my personal favorite is vega light
just from my own experiences at least at
the time i'm recording this video
that's october of 2020 i just found
vega lights to be the most mature the
most
flexible uh it's super powerful
it reminds me a lot of the capabilities
you can do with like ggplot2 from
r so it's my favorite and it's going to
be the one that i recommend you guys use
as well
now before we get into this tutorial
just a few asks from you guys
number one please smash the like button
to this video
it just takes half a second of your time
and it really helps my content reach a
larger audience
then also if you guys would be willing
to support me on patreon i do have a
link to that in the description of this
video
so if you guys are willing to do that it
wouldn't mean the world to me
also with this script as always that's
going to be available on my github repo
also in the video description now there
are a few links in here that
you guys may find helpful number one is
the link to the vega light documentation
it's fantastic and i highly recommend
reading that even after watching this
tutorial
and specifically i do highly recommend
learning how on the back end julia kind
of converts between the json
specification of vega and vega lite
into a format that's readable by the vl
plot macro
because once you understand that you can
just google certain things
with vega light and sometimes you're
going to see things that comes back
in this json specification and once you
understand how to go back and forth
between
one and the other it'll be much easier
for you to write code from scratch
then there are certain things that i
just am not going to be able to cover
throughout this video
specifically all the different marks and
configs out there
so i'm going to have uh links to those
here as well
alright so now let's get started so like
any other julia package
you're going to start by importing pkg
that's julius package manager
then you're going to run pkg.ad vega
lite
then at that point this is going to be
just like my tutorial on data frames if
you've seen that one first
i'm going to bring in our data sets
because that's where the data set i'm
going to be using for this tutorial is
going to come from
data frames i'm going to bring in and
then we're going to bring in vega light
as well
and now the data set that i'm going to
use here again that comes from
r specifically it's the mpg data set
from the ggplot2 package from r
so if you've seen my tutorial on gg plot
2
and r i'm going to walk through
basically the exact same
steps with the same data set that i did
there
so if we just use the describe function
from data frames just to get a feel for
this data
we get all the variables in the data set
as well as
mean minimum median maximum number of
unique values and the number of missing
values there
so now let's create our first vega light
plot
now i'm going to take this chunk of code
here and break down
every piece of this we start from our
mpg
data frame then think of this piece here
as just like a pipe operator
so we start from the data frame then we
pipe it to this functionality now vega
lite
operates through the at vl plot macro
and there is a subtle difference between
a macro and a function
i'll have a link in the description of
this video to a great reddit thread that
breaks down the distinction between a
macro and a function
but for now just remember our key macro
here is this at vl
plot thing and then on the inside this
operates just like a basic grammar of
graphics functionality
so the objects that we're using here are
called
marks and that's going to be our first
our first
argument so the mark that we're using
here
is a point because we just want to
create a simple scatter plot here
so a point is a type of mark the next
things that we're going to specify are
the x and the y
variable the x variable is the uh
displacement or displ variable
and then the y variable is the highway
miles per gallon or
hwy we can specify the width and the
height of the plot
object and then would you look at that
we have a pretty decent looking
uh vagalite plot object here so we've
created this really basic scatterplot
and it's got this basic blue color going
on here
but maybe we want to take this to the
next level and make these points red
instead of blue well at a high level
notice here
all we did was specify one argument
mark equals point x equals displacement
so on and so forth well for each and
every single one of these arguments
we can specify multiple components to
these arguments
by using braces and that's exactly what
we're going to do
here so what do i mean by that
so instead of specifying mark equals
point
we can allow for multiple different
arguments
to this argument by setting these braces
up
so instead of doing mark equals point
we're going to do
mark equals and then embraces points
comma
color equals red we do that and we get
this slightly nicer looking scatter plot
where the points are red instead of blue
so we're going to see many many more
examples of this
as we go through but first rather than
just
make these points all one
straightforward color
maybe we want to map the color to
another variable
so let me show you how to do that so one
thing to know
up front if you're mapping something to
a categorical variable
you want to specify whether you have a
nominal or an
ordinal categorical variable for those
of you unfamiliar
a nominal variable means the levels
aren't in any particular kind of order
but with an ordinal variable yeah there
is some kind of
inherent order to the levels so let's
take our class variable for instance
uh i'm gonna skip ahead actually here to
looking at the final plot
but if you look at the classes here like
two-seater compact
mid-size so on and so forth there's no
real
inherent order to that it's a nominal
variable
now how you encode that is you include
this colon n to the end of the variable
so what is this going to look like we
specify mark equals point
x equals displacement and y equals
highway just like we did before
but then we're going to make a new color
argument
at vl plot what we're going to do here
is just put it in quotes
and we're going to do class colon n
at the end the colon and specifies it
specifies that we have a nominal
variable
and then look at that it's looking
really fancy
the color is mapped to this class
variable if we look then at how julia
and vega light are gonna handle
uh ordinal variables here's another
example
so same kind of thing as before except
instead of
uh ending with the suffix colon n
we're going to end with colon o now i
did add a shape argument here too
just to show you that there's other
mappings that you can do and other
configurations to the plot that you can
change
now i specified cyl variable as nominal
to shape
it doesn't really matter but if you
specify
ordinal to shape julius is going to
throw a warning message
at you but again it doesn't really
matter we're going to do that
and then as far as the color is is
concerned
julia is going to throw a different
color spectrum
or almost like a different transparency
at you for the shades of blue here
and then notice that i have circle
square
triangle and and pluses here for the
different
uh values of the cyl variable so
again vega light very customizable
very flexible lots of different things
that you can change
now so far everything we've been working
with are scatter plots
so let's move on to another type of
visualization which is the column or bar
chart so a few things to break down in
this chunk of code here
first of all we're going to change mark
equals point to mark
equals bar and then unless you're
working with data that are
pre-aggregated
you need to specify some kind of
aggregation
function to either your y or to your x
because all i want to do here are return
the counts
for the class variable my aggregation
function is going to be
y equals count and then in parentheses
all these aggregation functions you can
use are specified in the vega light
documentation now to the color argument
i want to map this class variable as
well so i want every column here to be a
different color
and now vega light is going to allow us
to specify
our our scale or our
range of different colors manually i'm
going to do this here
julia is going to understand most uh
names of colors that you feed it but
then if you want to look up hex codes
that's obviously something that you can
do as well
then if we take a look at this uh
visualization it's looking pretty
colorful
like i said every column is going to be
a different color
and this just like everything else is
incredibly flexible so let's take a look
at another example
so in this case i'm gonna do a bar chart
instead of a column chart
by putting on the y-axis the variable
i'm interested in
and then on the x-axis the aggregation
function
now in the previous example i was
mapping
that same variable that was getting
aggregated to the color argument
but instead i'm going to pass a
different variable to the caller
argument i'm going to pass the cyl or
cylinder variable to the caller argument
so what i end up with here is a stacked
bar chart
the colors correspond to different
values of the cyl variable
and then as we go across this x-axis
we have the count of uh of records for
each of these different
uh values of the class variable so again
a stacked bar
chart now i'm going to show you another
example with the
mark equals bar and this is actually an
instance where
vega light is going to differ a lot from
like gg plot 2
and r if we want to build a histogram
there's not a special mark for that
we're still going to use mark equals bar
one
very important thing that we have to do
though is
under this x argument here we have to
specify
when we create our braces that bin
equals
true so make sure you include bin equals
true
keep mark equals a bar and in this case
here
i just want a green uh colored histogram
so i'm going to pass the color uh to the
mark
argument and then would you look at that
we have us
we have ourselves a scatter plot looks
pretty good not a whole lot more to
say about this it's pretty
straightforward right
the last object that i'm going to show
you how to create is a box plot
so hopefully now you have the hang of
this but
in mark we're going to specify box plot
and now there's actually a couple
different kinds of these that you can
create
depending on where you want to draw the
minimum and the maximum
lines here you can have them drawn to
the minimum and the maximum
some box plots are styled to where they
go to the first quartile and the third
quartile
and there's a tukey version that you can
specify under the extent
here but for this example we're going to
specify extent equals min
uh dash max so under the x and y
here you actually do have to put these
in quotes otherwise
uh it's going to freak out and not
recognize what you're doing
but again we do the mark equals box plot
here
then we get some pretty decent looking
box plots now we're going to tweak this
a little bit with a few
uh customizations so starting from the
same code that we had before
we're going to add a transform piece
here this is another thing vegalite is
going to allow us to do
now what we're going to do is transform
the source data going in here
so that the cyl variable does not equal
five there's the syntax here that you
have to specify
datum dot up front and because there's
no
data under the case where cyl equals
five
i want the case in which cuil does not
equal five
so we're going to do that inside uh
brackets rather than braces here
and then under column i'm going to
specify
the cyl variable because i want to
create different
facets here for this class variable and
visualizing the distribution of city
miles per gallon
broken down for different facets of the
cyl variable
now one thing i am going to do is make
the width here a little bit smaller so
that we can see each of these plots
and then look at that again for those of
you who are familiar with the
uh gg plot 2 package in r it's just like
i'm doing a facet wrap and it looks
just about as good i think now we're
going to do
one final plot for this tutorial and
there's going to be a lot going on here
and this is where we're going to throw
everything at the vl plot macro just to
give you an idea of
everything that we're going to be able
to tweak so
let's start from top to bottom we're
going to run the vl plot macro with mark
equals bar
and what we're going to do inside the x
argument is
for the axis we want the values to be
at a 30 degree angle let's scroll down a
little bit to show you what that looks
like
take a look at that the values we're
putting them at an angle
all right like before we're doing a
count
for our aggregation then we're going to
get this plot a title
that title is going to be records by
class
just like before color the class
variable is going to be mapped to the
color
argument we're going to manually specify
the range of colors
manually spell all those out just like
we did before
and then for our marks here or our
objects
maybe we want to make them a little bit
more transparent
we can do that using the opacity
argument
so we're going to give that a value of
0.7
the scale there is obviously 0 to 1.
then we get into this config argument so
there's
tons and tons of things that you can
pass to this more than i can get into in
this video
and all that is laid out in the in the
documentation
but let me give you an idea of some of
the things that we can do here
so first of all to this title piece here
we're going to make the title blue and
we're going to give it the font
uh times new roman this is fairly
flexible as far as the fonts are
concerned
i've played around with this and some
things it's not going to recognize but
times new roman everything is going to
recognize
for the legend i don't want a title to
that so i'm going to specify
title equals nothing now we get this
axis
thing here and then what we're going to
do here by specifying grid equals
false is we're going to get rid of all
these axis lines
which run along the panel or the
background of the plot
so just to show you a quick comparison
up here we've got all these lines going
on here
for our visualization here we don't want
that
the last few things i'm going to do here
are for the overall
border of our plot we're going to
specify that with the stroke
we'll give it a black border and then
we'll make it a little bit
thicker by specifying stroke width to
equal
two and then would you look at that
there's a lot that i did to that plot
and i configured it to
essentially my personal heart's content
and there's tons and tons of different
things that you can
experiment with too all right so that's
it for this tutorial
and in this video we covered a lot of
different things we created scatter
plots
column and bar charts we created box
plots and then we created facets for
them
and then we used all these different
configurations to make our graph
look a lot different but my real goal
here was kind of to teach you how to
fish
it was to show you how you can set up
different parameters
to the vl plot macro so that hopefully
you can go out there read the
documentation figure out all the
different things that you can do
inside the vo plot macro all the
different plots you can create
and that way suppose you're googling
things and looking around
you find something that's written using
the
using the json specification maybe you
want to emulate that using
uh the julia at vl plot macro
hopefully you can read that stuff out
there
and recreate that exact same plot inside
of julia
so thanks to all of you for watching
this video if you enjoyed it
uh please consider sharing this video
and also leave me a comment down below
and let me know how your
uh julia experience has worked out for
you so far
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data